last night's big story Donald Trump and
Mitt Romney had dinner together at an
expensive restaurant in New York City
called jean-georges they had they had a
meal together yeah the two billionaires
dined on fancy French cuisine and then
talked about how out of touch Washington
is mice little chat they had I'll get
you with the next seven the bananas like
let's go this is a real dinner they had
at their dinner together president-elect
Donald Trump and Mitt Romney dined on
sauteed frogs legs
true story yeah I don't know about you
but eating frogs legs with Donald
Trump's sound like someone lost a bet
[Applause]
yesterday yesterday president elect
Donald Trump had his third top secret
intelligence briefing yeah if you'd like
to know the details just check out
Trump's Twitter feed
[Applause]
this week Sarah Palin said that God
helped Donald Trump win the presidential
election yeah let's say she said God
helped a woman here went what
thank you I'll tell you again she
usually just says that at her TV but she
forgot you so you're at the tapings
listening no Sarah Palin said god help
Donald Trump win the presidential
election when he heard this a furious
Satan said don't I get credit for
anything
[Applause]
working hard to mine st. you do you
gotta have the pitchfork and you guys do
that you know yeah the horns - what is
that that just looks hard
it's pool cue chalk sharpening up the
horn you're not hoping that was crazy
this night shock you've got one banana
on your side that's it you need the pair
to really be on top hey good news for
recent college graduates in the next few
years the federal government is planning
to forgive 100 billion dollars of
student debt
[Applause]
so congratulations to six USC grads
[Applause]
this is kind of strange an expert panel
has recommended that a medically induced
pregnancy made from three people's DNA
could begin as early as next year three
people's yeah so finally some good news
for the Jonas Brothers they can have a
child that's every woman's dream a child
made of Nick and Joe and Brad Kevin what
Kevin what Kevin why do you know that
I'm real smart about stuff yeah don't
you have a poster in your dressing room
to Connecticut residents stole over
$1,000 worth of candles from the Yankee
Candle Village the suspects are being
described as white
[Applause]
you